hi Samuel leaves here and in this video
I'm going to reveal to you ten ways the
ten ways that I get paid from property
[Music]
so the first way that I make money from
property is through rent tenants pay me
rent I know it's kind of obvious there
are ten ways but it's really important
you can get more rent through a property
by being creative for instance by
turning it into a hey CH mo you know you
buy a house and rather than just renting
out to one family splitting it up
renting out on a room-by-room basis
tenants pay me rent and I see my tenants
as my customers it's really funny
actually you heard sometimes people will
stop me in the street and say Samuel I
saw you on the BBC landlord show oh my
gosh can I have your autograph you're
amazing you're such a nice landlord you
look after your tenants so well and then
two minutes later I'll be continuing to
walk down the street and someone will
shout out to me I saw you on that
landlord show you scum and I'm like wow
where did that come from
it was the same show it's so crazy
different people's perspectives but my
customers my tenants I love them rent is
fantastic because it's pretty much
passive when it is passive if you've got
a system I said that is number one
number two is capital appreciation
that's just where the house goes up in
value I mean I've been in property now
for ten years I've gone through quite a
bad recession and I've still received a
lot of capital appreciation in fact just
in the last six months I've made like
two hundred and fifty thousand pounds
just just just number so almost a
quarter of a million pounds in six
months just in capital appreciation and
one of my students I was chatting with
him last week he bought a house in
London it wasn't even a house it was an
apartment in 1999 right in London Centre
for 75,000 pounds and he got it on a 100
percent mortgage it's now worth seven
hundred thousand pounds 1819 years later
it's time to sit stealth by 10 in 19
years which is just insane so capital
appreciation is a really good way that I
make money from property it's how most
people become millionaires by mistake
I'm happy to be an accidental
millionaire as well as a deliberate
millionaire so that's number two number
three and this is different from rents
because they're not tenants but a
serviced accommodation service
accommodation is
a hotel without staff so the service
accommodation property is one where you
you rent it out as a hotel but you don't
have to employ staff it's all systemized
it's something that I'm doing a lot at
the moment in fact the castle that I'm
buying is probably going to be done as a
look through serviced accommodation
property and it's just a really good way
of getting a sky-high income from
property the cool think about serviced
accommodation is that it's when you when
you when you systemize it properly and
you buy in the right area it can be
extremely lucrative multiple of my
students are doing serviced
accommodation very successfully if you'd
like to watch Leslie's story of how
she's making fifteen thousand pounds a
month within four months of becoming my
student you can watch that right here
next while I make money from property is
a strategy called rent to rent this is
not something that I actively really
look for anymore but it was quite
helpful in the earlier days it's
something that my students do really
really successfully and I've done many
times as well and that is simply where
you take over a property you don't buy
it you make money from if you don't buy
it you control it so you take over a
property and you rent it off the
landlord but then you add value to the
tenants and you make it like for
instance let's say you rent a single
that property and you pay five hundred
pounds to the landlord but then you went
out on a room-by-room basis and went out
for fifteen hundred pounds and then any
difference the profit you make you keep
it's a really cool way to make some
instant cash flow from property without
really putting any money down or much
down to begin with ready to rent really
cool when you can tie that in with HMO
serviced accommodation or whatever you
please just make sure if you do that you
use the right contracts you don't use a
normal esti contract you need a special
rent to rent agreement which you can get
drawn up pretty pretty easily for very
inexpensive number five is my favorite
or one of them lease option agreement
what is a lease option agreement
it's simply where you buy a house today
but agree to pay for it later
completely legal when done right people
say oh that sounds a bit dodgy no if you
use the right word the vendors will go
for it iffy and if you do it properly
it's completely legal
lease option option agreements have been
around for decades and decades and
decades so how does this work let's say
I find a house it's on for a hundred
thousand pounds but they can't serve
having issues they're in negative
equities and in Harry
property they're not to do with it look
whatever I say I'll buy off you for a
hundred but I'll pay you in five years
time and in the meantime I'll take over
the mortgage or I pay you a small
monthly sum maybe a hundred pounds a
month or whatever then you take on the
property you benefit immediately from
the cash flow the rent from the property
you're also gaining from any capital
appreciation and you haven't put down
any of your own money apart from maybe
the drawing up the contract so these
option agreement is fantastic you can
also do them for really big deals it's
something that I've done for many many
years and I'm actively still doing lease
option agreements today and many of my
students do Lease Option agreements as
well so that is number five number six
is commercial property commercial
property is something that I'm beginning
to get into more these days and the
reason is is because what is commercial
property it's instead of buying a
residential house and renting out to
tenants people that live there are
commercial properties when you buy a
property or a building which is used for
commercial purposes so for instance if
it's a shop in its offices anything
covers a garage anything that's used for
business purposes now the reason that
commercial is so awesome is because
instead of having a six month contract
with a tenant you tend to have a ten
year five-year ten-year fifteen year
contract with a business and the
business usually it depends on what the
contracts are but typically with
commercial property is the business they
will deal with any repairs any issues
they will deal with it it's a very long
contract and you can kind of switch off
so when I had my conversation with Lord
Sugar
he was like residential how do you how
do you deal with all the boilers
breaking up stuff like that because he's
used to commercial so I think commercial
is good especially if you've got lots of
money or you've been in residential for
a while you're financially free and you
really want to just really grow your
portfolio and take it big but you don't
necessarily want hundreds and hundreds
of residential properties it would make
sense to just buy a big office block
here's the thing okay a lot of people
think the commercial property the
returns are a lot less but it's more
stable that's not true some of my
commercial properties they give me
twenty four percent so commercial
property can still be high return
capital depreciation is usually not as
quick to go up I don't want to give like
tax advice or anything like that so
speak to your accountant but you can buy
commercial property through a pension
and there's very there's very strong tax
advantages for buying commercial
property so loving loving commercial
property right now number seven is to
buy refurbish refinance and rent they
don't have to quite do it like that but
that's typically the standard way that
we do it what that is is if you've got
money but you don't want to put it into
a property and just dump it in and leave
it in you can put it in and then pull it
back out now some people some trainers
make it sound much much simpler than it
is this does come with a little bit of
work and even a little bit of risk
because when you're relying on builders
sticking to budgets and timescales and
value as being in a good mood it can
always get down values or things can
always not happen quite the way to plan
however we have got many of our students
doing this successfully that have come
through the crash course and especially
the ones that I've got on to join the
Academy the first house that I bought I
bought it below market value and then I
refinanced it and pulled out all of my
money now that was 2000 and like I ran
about 2008 so it is different now the
best way to do it now is to buy and add
value and then refinance Kemp reliant a
mortgage lender who are very very
well-known and popular amongst investors
have just banned the six month to rule
which means that you can literally
refine that straightaway there's no rule
so as soon as you've bought and added
value you can refine that some point
your money out straight away which is
fantastic so this is a strategy it's
becoming more more popular with my
students you could literally buy a
50,000 pound house spend 20 grand on it
or 15 grand on it and then and then if
the value has gone considerably up you
can refinance and pull all or most of
your money out or you can do this with
you know like the castle the castle I'm
buying which is I mentioned a couple
times because it's a castle and you've
probably seen the videos that's going to
be we're going to add value and
refinance and we're going to add value
to that by turning into apartments you
know you can you can buy a property and
split it up you can title split' you can
refurbish you cuz there's so many ways
you can add value and once you've added
the value then you can refine that so
that's number seven number eight which
is kind of similar to number seven is to
buy em sell buy a house add value in
then sell it at the moment on doing this
to a piece of land I'm buying a piece of
land I bought it for 100 that or I'm
buying it's not gone through yet but I'm
buying it for a hundred thousand pounds
and then I'm gonna get planning
permission and set it for a whole lot
more the problem with buying and selling
is
that again it can come with a little bit
of risk because what happens if you
can't sell it so you usually need an
exit strategy or a plan B and also the
other negative with it is that it's not
passive income but it is massive income
and massive income can very quickly
become passive income because if you do
a deal I make 100 grand or half a
million or whatever or even 20 grand you
can then with that profit put it into
just buying a buy to let or a HMO or
whatever so it's nice to have two ORS
massive passive massive passive going on
together which takes me on to the next
way number 9 which is deal packaging
deal packaging what I mean by that that
is finding property deals that might not
be suitable for yourself you might not
be able to afford to buy them you might
already have too many deals going
through but then you package the deal
package it up and pass it on to an
investor you marry an investment
property with an investor and you charge
a fee in the middle it's just a
fantastic way to make money but also get
experience has been out there finding
deals I personally think that most
investors I mean certainly most of my
students end up doing this to some
extent do you make sure if you do this
that you do pass only good deals and
also that you're compliant there is
there is there is a compliance issue you
need to go through which is very
straightforward one of our Academy
members called Alastair he is sourcing
successfully and in interview of him
last week which was videoed and last
month he made 27,000 pounds that's like
two seven zero zero zero just by
packaging and passing deals on to people
and it's doing that consistently every
month if you want to hear his story and
see how he's doing that then you can
check out the interview with him just
right here
but finally is number 10 and this isn't
quite how I make money from property but
this is also how I make money which is
from training people how to successfully
invest as well I teach people for free
on YouTube also my crash course is free
I have my book which I give out for free
on my website but then some people want
to go further and want to get like maybe
mentored or coached and I also run a
training business I've run a very
successful property training business
and it kind of shocks me and makes me
laugh when people say if you're such a
successful investor in developer then
why do you train people I'm thinking
that came from such a stupid person or
maybe not stupid people it's certainly a
broke person I had dinner with Richard
Branson okay maybe like six months ago
imagine if I'd have said to him so
Richard
if you're playing a business he's making
so much money then why do you run trains
he'd slap me right across the face
because he's an entrepreneur you know so
I love teaching I really enjoy it it
gives me a real buzz I love seeing
people succeed and I also will happily
take the money because I'm an
entrepreneur as well money is a
certificate and if someone gives you
money whether that be a tenant or
anybody at all in business or someone
that you're training they're giving you
money as a thank-you certificate for
adding value so I'm very happy to add
value and help people and take their
money because if I've helped someone
make a hundred thousand pounds and
they've given me ten thousand pounds
then they're 90 thousand pounds up and
I'm ten thousand pounds off it's win-win
so that's what another way hope that
video has been helpful hope it inspired
you if you've got questions let me know
also I'd love to know which your
favorite strategy is amongst the ten and
which one you want to really smash this
next year so please comment below what
is your favorite property investment
strategy your favorite way to make money
comment below please do share and
subscribe like the video thank you for
your support love you always see you
next time thank you so much for watching
if you benefit just on that video please
do share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time